so tragedy struck my family on friday
when i got the news which came
completely out of nowhere hitting like a
bolt of lightning from the clear blue
sky
that i had been suspended from twitter
these are truly the times that try men's
souls i was informed of the suspension
mere moments after posting a video of me
defeating my wife
in a plastic sled race in our front yard
now at first i thought that i was being
suspended because of that video perhaps
on a bullying charge or something either
way you know that's the kind of
indispensable content that the internet
was deprived of in my absence then i
received the email from our twitter
overlords they informed me that the
suspension was for two offensive posts
that i had recently authored
one said this
trigger warning get ready for this this
is what it says
the greatest female jeopardy champion of
all time is a man the top female college
swimmer is a man the first female
four-star admiral in the public health
service is a man men have dominated
female high school track and the female
mma circuit the patriarchy wins in the
end
the other was a tweet from a few months
ago i think was a few months ago and i
was responding i believe to the news
that demi lovato had come out as a they
them she had come out as multiple people
where i said in my trademark diplomatic
and gentle style
i am not referring to an individual
person as if she is two people everyone
else can run around sounding like
maniacs if they want to but i will not
be participating no thank you
well i did say no thank you so i think i
was pretty polite about it
what rules did these two posts violate
well the company said that i had run
afoul of their policy prohibiting
hateful conduct
what is hateful conduct
that's this is the only explanation they
offer for that they say
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease
now it should be noted that you can
still promote violence against them if
you just disagree with their opinions
because people do that to me every
single day i mean every day someone is
telling me they're gonna kill me or
wishing death on my entire family but
that's okay because they just hate me
for everything i stand for and believe
that's totally fine
hate somebody for their race or gender
on the other hand well that is
unacceptable
but did i promote violence i mean did i
make any threats against anybody
i said the patriarchy wins but that was
simply an observation not a threat
i didn't say the patriarchy will win you
fools you're all gonna pay
that's the kind of thing i might say
but that's not what i mean that's what i
hope it will happen but that's that's
not what i actually said
so where was the threat or was i guilty
of harassment
was i harassing the trans jeopardy
contestant by simply observing in a
tweet where he was not tagged or even
mentioned by name that he's a biological
male
now if i had to guess and all i can do
is guess because social media companies
never deign to explain themselves to
plebes like us but if i had to guess
that's what i would think they probably
determined that i was harassing trans
people by making objectively correct
statements
and not even again making those
statements to them but just in general
in much the same way that i guess that
my math teachers in elementary school
harassed me by telling me that i was
doing long division wrong
you know the truth is harassment if you
don't want to hear it
that seems to be the standard though
rather unevenly applied of course
now fortunately i was let out of uh of
time out the next day and i was
permitted to continue posting
um
you know whatever i want i mean posting
videos of my sled races if i wanted to
but whether i can continue to post
scientifically correct information about
sex and gender is another matter
i will continue to do it we'll just see
how much more they tolerate before
before they ban me
now although my twitter suspension was
obviously a great hardship for me and
i'm still struggling with ptsd from the
experience i'm aware that it's not
exactly earth-shattering news for
everybody else
especially because this kind of thing
happens all the time
the point that has greater implications
for society is not that this or that
individual person gets suspended or
banned
it's that the most powerful social media
platforms on the planet
have forbidden us from stating basic
objective truths
now although we have perhaps grown
accustomed to it by now
it is nonetheless mind-numbingly
deranged that multi-billion dollar
companies have decided that you cannot
say
biological males are men
many of the dystopian novelists of the
20th century were able to correctly
predict various aspects of our society
today but none of them predicted this
none of them prophesied a future a near
future where it's considered harassment
to observe that an individual with a
penis is a man
this goes far beyond the darkest
nightmares of orwell or huxley
and it of course extends beyond social
media there are efforts now to impose
these kinds of rules on the entire
country from the federal level in the
form of bills like the equality act
school districts have adopted these
policies like in loudoun county major
corporations across the spectrum have
imposed them on their employees
and we cannot lose sight of just how
exceedingly psychotic all of this truly
is
now of course i say psychotic in a
colloquial sense
um the people imposing these rules are
not actually crazy
some of these people that are imposing
the rules on behalf of are crazy
but the people coming up with the rules
are not crazy
they are acting with intent and with
clear and coherent goals in mind
part of what drives a censorship is that
the left's gender ideology
is a fragile and vulnerable thing and
they know it
it cannot stand up to the slightest
scrutiny
it can only be defended if all of the
opponents are cleared from the playing
field ahead of time it could only stand
up if no wind is allowed to blow
over at the university of pennsylvania
biological male swimmer leah thomas
just won this this just few days ago
first place in the 200 and 500 yard
freestyle races in a meet against
females
now he was defeated
in the 100 freestyle uh race however by
yale's isaac hennig who is also
transgender
so a trans
person beat another trans person in the
female me now the interesting thing is
that hennig is a female who now
identifies as male which means that in
the women's competition men who call
themselves women are allowed to
participate but so are women who call
themselves men
it is total indefensible insanity
though a journalist on nbc this weekend
tried to defend it anyway and let's
listen to that
so let's talk about it now with joe
yorkeva from nbc out who just published
the speech with the latest about leah
joe i'm glad to have you glad to have
you here talk about what's going on here
right um because leah does have support
from her team from her school from her
league if you will and yet for some of
her detractors that doesn't seem to be
enough
sure yeah so there are a few different
arguments happening here you've got an
argument about fairness there are people
who oppose trans women competing in
women's sports because they say it's
unfair to cisgender women who aren't
trans most of whom don't receive the
athletic athletic advantages of higher
testosterone levels during puberty
though then you have folks who say
there's very little scientific evidence
that shows that those advantages carry
over for trans women after transition so
then you've got this argument about
fairness and human rights on the other
side and trans advocates say that this
question of inclusion is about more than
just sports because you know we're still
seeing these efforts at the state level
to ban trans people from using the
bathrooms of their gender so they say
this debate is really part of a larger
conversation about whether trans people
can participate in certain aspects of
society at all just one minute there and
somehow they managed to pack like a half
dozen lies into it every word of what
you just heard is false
it's not true that leah thomas has
support from his teammates
they hate the fact that he's there they
by no means are thrilled to have this
big bulky guy intruding in their space
but they'll be punished if they say
anything on the record about it they
have talked off the record but that's
all they can do
as for the claim that there's no
scientific evidence that biological
males have advantages in sports that
would be true if you simply ignore
literally all of the evidence because
every piece of evidence available
confirms over and over and over again
that males have an advantage
i mean every single piece of evidence
there is no evidence on the other side
of this
and yet it's not even our side that
needs to produce evidence
if you wish to contradict thousands of
years of human knowledge and
experience which are free to do
it's you who must meet the burden of
proof
you must provide evidence that they
don't have an advantage which you have
not and never will because you can't
and it's also not true that people are
trying to stop transgenders from
participating from participating in
society nobody has made any such attempt
or suggested anything like that
i am not aware of any law or any
proposal anywhere at any point
that would prohibit trans people from
using the bathroom
that would not be a sanitary policy for
one thing it also certainly wouldn't be
fair the question is whether trans
people should be required to stick with
their biological sex in these contexts
or if they should get special treatment
so once again everything you heard there
was a lie
because all they can do is lie
which is no surprise
given that they are waging a war on
truth
and that's what this is about
but the lies are so brazen so empty
so glaringly obvious and false
that the truth just cannot be allowed
within its proximity at all
the lies would shrivel and die
they cannot endure the slightest
challenge
that's why they censor
what other choice do they have
tell the truth i mean well they
obviously can't do that well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content